Enchanted toilets, Frozen easter eggs, and
shirtless scenes are just some of the deleted
scenes and rejected concepts from Disney's
live-action Beauty And The Beast.
Yippee-ki-yay movie lovers, it's Jan here,
and in this video I'm going to reveal some
of the scenes and ideas that were cut from
2017's Beauty And The Beast movie.
Just before I start, I'm giving away a second
copy of this amazing Disney hardback book
from DK, which is loaded with behind-the-scenes
artwork, photos, and information about Disney's
live-action and animated movies.
For a chance to win, all you have to do is
subscribe and leave a comment about the new
Beauty And The Beast movie or the deleted
scenes on this video.
And for bonus ways to enter, check out the
Gleam link in the video description below.
A quick warning there will be spoilers in
this video, so just be aware of that or you
can watch my spoiler-free review here and
come back after you've seen the movie.
When I interviewed Beauty And The Beast director
Bill Condon, he told me all about a funny
deleted scene that involved LeFou and a new
enchanted character called Monsieur Toilette
and which took place during the battle between
the enchanted objects and the villagers at
the Beast's castle.
If you recall, leading up to the battle, LeFou
had already begun to question his allegiance
to Gaston, and in the deleted scene he opens
one of the castle's doors to hide away from
the fighting.
Unfortunately for LeFou, behind this particular
door is an enchanted bathroom, and Monsieur
Toilette attacks him, drenching him with water.
Later when the household objects change back
to human form, Monsieur Toilette, who is played
by Stephen Merchant, feels disgusted that
he's had to spend 10 years as an enchanted
toilet and he shares another funny moment
with Josh Gad's LeFou.
Bill Condon explained that the Monsieur Toilette
scene was cut for time and also because the
humour was considered a bit low-brow in comparison
to the rest of the scene.
The battle scene also had other moments cut,
including one where the enchanted stove attacks
the Village Lasses, which is what the Bimbettes
were called in the live-action movie.
And just before the battle, Gaston rallies
the villagers with the rousing Mob Song.
As well some altered lyrics, you might have
noticed that there's a section of the song
missing from the theatrical release.
You can listen to the missing lyrics by Luke
Evans, Josh Gad and the villagers on the official
soundtrack, but the deleted section is from
a scene on the way to the castle where the
mob creep past the wolves singing, "We don't
like what we don't understand.
In fact, it scares us.
And this monster is mysterious at least."
Bill Condon was sad to cut this scene as it
was so beautiful, but explained that it ended
up downplaying the tension of the moment and
was also cut for time.
Given how incredibly popular Disney's animated
Beauty And The Beast movie is and the fact
it won two Oscars for its music, it seems
unbelievable that early in development the
studio wanted to completely overhaul the story
and cut out all the songs.
Apparently, at the time, the studio wanted
to go in a similar direction to the 2012 movie
Snow White And The Huntsman, which starred
Kristen Stewart.
It wasn't until the huge success of Frozen
in 2013 that Disney realised there was enormous
potential in a musical remake, however, the
studio was still unsure and wanted to just
do half the songs from the original movie.
Director Bill Condon, who has a strong musical
background with films like Chicago and Dreamgirls,
refused to take on the project until Disney
recognised that a full-on musical was the
best approach.
I absolutely love Alan Menken and Howard Ashman's
songs from the 1991 film, so I'm really glad
that the studio did come to its senses and
go for a proper musical movie in the end,
and even added some new songs by Menken and
Tim Rice.
Speaking of music and live-action remakes
of Disney movies, it'll be interesting to
see just how much music actually makes it
into the live-action version of Mulan as director
Niki Caro first said there wouldn't be any
songs, but later said there will be music.
When I interviewed Emma Watson and Dan Stevens
about the movie, they explained that there
were plans for a scene involving Belle where
she convinced Beast to convert his vast personal
library into a public space or public library.
Belle wanted to open up the knowledge to the
whole world and it was also going to be a
place where she would combine her passion
for books and teaching and educating others,
much as we see her do at the beginning of
the movie.
Emma Watson said she was gutted when the public
library idea didn't make it into the final
film, but according to Dan Stevens there wasn't
room for it in the shape of the final story.
There's also a picture of a deleted scene
between Belle and the beggar woman Agathe,
who's the Enchantress in disguise and this
scene looks like it probably happened early
in the movie.
By the way, if you'd like to discover all
the secrets of the new live-action Enchantress,
then tap in the top right of the screen to
check out my video.
There's a wonderful moment in the original
movie where LeFou gets covered in snow like
a snowman outside Belle's house.
Josh Gad, who plays LeFou and is the voice
of Olaf the snowman in Frozen, says he begged
Bill Condon to include the scene in the live-action
movie as it's such a great easter egg and
in-joke for Disney fans.
Sadly, the scene never made it into the final
film, perhaps because it wouldn't have fit
in the new version because there wasn't any
need for LeFou to spy on Belle's house as
he did in the animation.
In the final transformation scene where Beast
turns back into the prince, Dan Stevens reportedly
filmed scenes where he was shirtless and rose
up from a layer of rose petals.
Rather different then to his shirtless scene
in the horror-thriller The Guest.
During Beauty And The Beast test screenings,
though, it was felt that the way the scene
was shot made it look like Dan Stevens was
perhaps fully naked, so the scene ended up
being cut.
And Luke Evans explained that the moment in
the original animation where Gaston reveals
that "every last inch of [him's] covered with
hair" was also cut because it wasn't considered
family friendly enough.
Now, I'd love to know what you thought about
the deleted scenes which didn't make it into
the final movie!
And is there anything from the original film
you wish had been included?
Don't forget to comment and subscribe for
your chance to win a second copy of this awesome
Disney hardback book!
And if you enjoyed this, I'd really appreciate
your likes and shares, and you can tap or
click here to watch more of my Beauty And
The Beast videos, including my Disney theory
video about the Enchantress and my video with
easter eggs and things you missed in the new
movie.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers.